>>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
PETER NAVARRO IS THE PITCHER OF
A LAW-ABIDING AMERICAN CITIZEN.
A 72-YEAR-OLD RETIRED BUSINESS
SCHOOL PROFESSOR WHO HAS A PHD
FROM HARVARD UNIVERSITY.
HIS MOST RECENT JOB WAS
EXTREMELY WHITE-COLLAR.
HE SERVED AS THE WHITE HOUSE
TRADE ADVISOR IN THE LAST
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION.
FAMOUS FOR HIS TOUGH STANCE ON
CHINA.
HE'S NEVER BEEN CHARGED WITH A
CRIME AND HAS NEVER PACKAGED
FENTANYL FROM MEXICO.
HE PROBABLY DOES YOGA AND IS
RIDING HIS BICYCLE.
PETER DOES NOT SEEM LIKE A
CRIMINAL, MUCH LESS A DANGER TO
THIS NATION.
AND YET LAST FRIDAY FEDERAL
AGENTS ARRESTED PETER NAVARRO A
REAGAN NATIONAL AIRPORT IN
WASHINGTON.
THEY DID NOT CALL HIS LAWYER AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN CASES LIKE THIS.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN COME TO HIS
HOUSE.
IT WAS FEET FROM THE FBI
BUILDING.
THEY COULD HAVE WALKED, BUT THE
DIDN'T.
INSTEAD THEY TOOK HIM DOWN IN
PUBLIC AS YOU WOULD A FUGITIVE
TERROR MASTERMIND SO EVERYONE
COULD SEE IT AND LEARN THE
LESSONS THEY WERE SENDING.
THEY HANDCUFFED PETER NAVARRO
AND PUT HIM IN LEG IRONS AND
THREW HIM INTO A CELL.
HE IS NOW FACING YEARS IN PRISON
.
SO WHAT DID PETER NAVARRO DO TO
DESERVE TREATMENT LIKE THIS?
HE RESISTED A SUBPOENA FROM THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE.
THE JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE IS
WASHINGTON'S LATEST INQUISITION
RUN BY NANCY PELOSI WITH HELP
FROM LIZ CHENEY AND ADAM
KINZINGER.
NAVARRO RESISTED THAT SUBPOENA
BECAUSE HE HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH JANUARY 6TH.
NOTHING WHATSOEVER.
THAT IS NOT DISPUTED.
PETER NAVARRO DID NOT BREAK INT
THE CAPITOL.
HE DID NOT ENCOURAGE ANYONE ELS
TO BREAK INTO THE CAPITOL.
HE WAS NOT THERE THAT DAY AND
HAD NO IDEA IT WOULD HAPPEN.
THAT IS BEYOND DISPUTE AND NANC
PELOSI AND LIZ CHENEY KNOW THAT.
IF YOU REALLY WANTED TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6T
LAST PERSON YOU WOULD TALK TO.
YOU WOULD BE TALKING TO RAY EPP
AND VARIOUS FBI INFORMANTS.
FINDING OUT WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH AND WHY IS NOT THE
POINT OF THE EXERCISE.
THE POINT OF THE EXERCISE IS
PREVENTING DONALD TRUMP FROM
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN.
IN THE SERVICE OF THAT GOAL,
PELOSI AND LIZ CHENEY DEMANDED
THAT NAVARRO SURRENDER
CONVERSATIONS WITH PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP, HIS FORMER BOSS.
WHEN HE REFUSED TO DO THAT
CONGRESS HELD HIM IN CONTEMPT
AND THEN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
FILED CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST
PETER NAVARRO.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY CIVILIZED
COUNTRIES OPERATE.
JUST BECAUSE YOU CONTROL THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE HOUSES OF
CONGRESS DOES NOT MEAN YOU GET
TO THROW YOUR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS BEHIND BARS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE DO IN AMERICA
.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO IN HAITI.
BUT THAT IS WHAT WE ARE DOING
NOW.
PETER NAVARRO IS NOT THE FIRST.
BIDENS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ALSO
ARRESTED STEVE BANNON FOR A
SIMILAR FAKE CRIME.
STEVE BANNON IS AWAITING TRIAL
THIS SUMMER.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING WE HAVE
SEEN BEFORE.
IT'S A HUGE STEP TOWARD THE
POLITICS OF A THIRD WORLD.
THE MEDIA JOB IS TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST POWER.
THEY ARE APPLAUDING BECAUSE IT
TURNS OUT NO PUNISHMENT IS TOO
SEVERE FOR THOSE WHO DISAGREE
WITH THE NATIONAL NEWS MEDIA.
WATCH THEM GLOAT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO PETER NAVARRO
IS WHAT SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED TO
PETER NAVARRO.
HE WAS INDICTED.
WHEN YOU ARE INDICTED, YOU ARE
ARRESTED.
>> WHAT PETER NAVARRO DID WAS S
FAR OUT OF BOUNDS AND
INDEFENSIBLE.
THIS PROSECUTION IS ABOUT
PUNISHING NAVARRO BASED ON HIS
BLATANT DISRESPECT FOR THE
CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA.
>> THEY REALLY ARE YOUR ENEMIES.
THEY ARE NOT COVERING THE NEWS.
THEY ARE PLOTTING WAYS TO HURT
YOU.
THAT IS TRUE.
THEY ARE NOT OPTIONAL.
THEY LECTURE YOU.
COMPLY WITH THEM OR GO TO JAIL.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE THE LAWYERS
ON TELEVISION ARE SAYING.
LET'S PRETEND FOR A MOMENT THAT
WAS TRUE THAT FACT NOT TRUE.
IF THERE WAS IN FACT A LOT LIKE
THAT, FOR THAT LOT TO BE
LEGITIMATE OF WOULD HAVE TO BE
LIKE ALL LAWS APPLIED FULLY
ACROSS THE BOARD AND NO LESS
THEN THE INTERNING GENERAL
HIMSELF SAID THAT AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
I CAME TO WORK HERE BECAUSE WE
ARE COMMITTED TO THE RULE OF LA
AND TO SEEKING EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
THAT IS MERRICK GARLAND IN
JANUARY.
QUOTE, WE CONDUCT EVERY
INVESTIGATION GUIDED BY THE SAM
NORMS.
NOW, THOSE ARE THE NORMS UNDER
WHICH THIS COUNTRY HAS LIVED FO
250 YEARS.
IT IS NOT JUSTICE UNLESS IT'S
APPLIED EQUALLY TO ALL ADULT
AMERICAN CITIZENS, PERIOD.
ANYTHING LESS THAN THAT IS NOT
JUSTICE.
BUT WE ARE GETTING MUCH LESS
THAN THAT AND IT'S VERY OBVIOUS.
HERE IS ONE EXAMPLE.
10 YEARS AGO THIS MONTH CONGRES
VOTED OVERWHELMINGLY ON A
BIPARTISAN VOTE, 17 DEMOCRATS,
TO HOLD ERIC HOLDER THE THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
HOLDER HAD REFUSED TO TURN OVER
DOCUMENTS SHOWING HOW THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION HAD ARMED THE
MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS.
REMEMBER THAT?
ONE WITH FIREARMS THEY SENT TO
MEXICO AND THE FAST AND FURIOUS
PROGRAM WAS THEN USED TO MURDER
AN AMERICAN BORDER PATROL
OFFICER.
IT WAS A SCANDAL AT THE TIME IN
CASE YOU DON'T RECALL.
>> HE DIED IN DECEMBER 2010,
KILLED BY GUNS TIED TO AN OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PLANNED THAT
ARMED MEXICANS.
THE SCANDAL OFFICIALS TRIED TO
HIDE IT BY WRONGLY CLAIMING
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
E-MAILS CONTAINING THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES REPORTS
SHOWED TOP OFFICIALS KNEW THEY
SENT GUIDANCE TO MEXICO EVEN
BEFORE HIS DEATH.
THE BORDER PATROL WHICH SENT TH
TEAM INTO THE DESERT DIDN'T KNO
ABOUT THE OPERATION.
>> THAT WAS A LEGITIMATE SCANDA
THAT IMPLICATED THE ENTIRE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE POWER, NOT
RETIREE SITTING IN JAIL BECAUSE
OF WHAT THEY DID ON ASK JANUARY
6.
ERIC HOLDER WAS THE VERY CENTER
OF IT.
BUT IF HOLDER REFUSED TO COMPLY
WITH THE SUBPOENA FROM THE
CONGRESS.
DID THE FBI ARREST ERIC HOLDER
FOR THAT?
PLEASE.
HE WAS NEVER EVEN SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERED.
HOLDER ASSERTED EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, MEANING THE RIGHT TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
EXECUTIVES THAT ARE PRIVATE.
HE CITED THE LONG-STANDING
POLICY OF RESPECTING EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AND HE GOT AWAY WITH
IT.
A WEEK AGO PETER NAVARRO MADE
THIS EXACT POINT.
HE SUEDE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
PUSHING BACK AGAINST THE
SUBPOENA FOUR DAYS BEFORE HE WA
ARRESTED.
IN THAT SUIT NAVARRO CITED
POLICY WRITTEN BY THE DOJ LEGAL
COUNSEL.
IT READS THIS WAY.
QUOTE, SINCE THE 1970S THIS
OFFICE CONSISTENTLY ADVISE THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS IMMEDIATE
ADVISORS ARE ABSOLUTELY IMMUNE
FROM TESTIMONIAL COMPULSION BY
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE ON
MATTERS RELATED TO THEIR
OFFICIAL DUTIES, AND A QUOTE.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF SOMEBODY
ASSERTS EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AT
THE VERY LEAST CONGRESS DOESN'T
GET TO ARREST THEM.
BEFORE ANYONE IS ARRESTED THEY
HAVE TO GO TO A JUDGE TO RULE O
WEATHER OR NOT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IS VALID IN THIS CASE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN ERIC
HOLDER'S CASE.
THE FEDERAL JUDGE REJECTED ERIC
HOLDER'S CLAIM AND STILL HE WAS
NOT ARRESTED.
WHY?
YOU KNOW WHY.
BECAUSE HE'S A LEADING DEMOCRAT.
BUT IN PETER NAVARRO'S CASE
MERRICK GARLAND DID NOT EVEN
BOTHER TO ASK A JUDGE.
THEY JUST ARRESTED PETER NAVARR
AT NATIONAL AIRPORT.
SO WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE ISN'
REALLY ABOUT PETER NAVARRO OR
STEVE BANNON.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS A MASSIVE
ESCALATION IN THE USE BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM FOR PARTISAN REVENGE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THAT WAS.
PETER NAVARRO WOULD NOT SHUT UP
SO THEY THREW HIM IN HANDCUFFS.
IN FACT, AT THE SAME MOMENT
PETER NAVARRO WAS THROWN IN JAI
FOR SERVING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
A CLINTON LAWYER WAS ACQUITTED
BY A JURY SEATED BY AN OBAMA
APPOINTED JUDGE.
THREE OF THE JURORS IN THAT CAS
GAVE MONEY TO HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN AND THOSE SAME JURORS
DECLINED TO PUNISH MICHAEL
SUSSMAN FOR LYING TO THE FBI TO
ADVANCE THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
MYTH THAT HELPED HILLARY CLINTON
'S CAMPAIGN.
FOLLOWING ALL OF THIS?
HOW DID THOSE JURORS GET ON THE
JURY AND STAY THERE?
THE FBI PRETENDED TO BE OUTRAGE
BY THE FACT THAT MICHAEL SUSSMA
HAD LIED TO THEM BUT THEN WE
LEARNED ACTUALLY THE FBI WAS
WORKING WITH F MICHAEL SUSSMAN
AND HIS LAW FIRM PERKINS KHOI.
PERKINS KHOI HAD AN FBI
WORKSPACE IN ITS OFFICES IN
WASHINGTON FOR A DECADE.
MICHAEL SUSSMAN WAS SO CLOSE TO
THE FBI HE HAD A KEY CARD TO FB
HEADQUARTERS.
WE KNOW THIS FROM A RECENTLY
RELEASED TEXT EXCHANGE.
WE ARE QUOTING.
DO HAVE A BADGE OR NEED HELP
GETTING INTO THE BUILDING?
THE FBI IS GENERAL COUNSEL JAME
BAKER ASKED SUSSMAN.
WE ARE QUOTING NOW.
I HAVE A BADGE SUSSMAN REPLIED.
SUSSMAN HAD A BADGE TO THE FBI
BUILDING?
HOW DO WE GET ONE OF THOSE?
WE ARE NOT LEADING DEMOCRATIC
LAWYERS SO WE CANNOT HAVE THEM.
MICHAEL SUSSMAN KNEW HE WOULD
NEVER BE PUNISHED.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
"THE FEDERALIST" BEEN WHITE
GARDEN EXPLAINS HOW WE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THESE TWO
PROSECUTIONS.
QUOTE, THEY SEND AN UNMISTAKABL
MESSAGE.
WE CAN GET YOU ANYTIME, ANYWHER
ON ANY GROUNDS WE CHOOSE.
YOU CANNOT TOUCH A SINGLE ONE O
OURS.
THAT'S IT RIGHT THERE.
THIS IS A PARTISAN PLAY BY A
POLITICAL PARTY THAT IS SOMEHOW
COMPLETELY TAKEN OVER OUR
LARGEST LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
SUSSMAN IS NOT EVEN THE BIGGEST
EXAMPLE OF THIS.
ANDREW McCABE, LISA PAGE,
PETER STRZOK.
ALL OF THEM LEAD TO THE FEDS AS
WELL.
THAT'S A CRIME.
NONE WERE HAULED OFF AND LEG
IRONS.
THEY ARE NOW AT CNN, MSNBC AND
GEORGETOWN RESPECTIVELY.
THEY WERE REWARDED WITH BETTER
JOBS FOR WHAT THEY DID.
THEY ALWAYS ARE.
JIM CLAPPER AND JOHN BRENNAN
COMMITTED PERJURY ON TELEVISION
BEFORE CONGRESS.
THERE IS NO DISPUTE ABOUT THAT.
WHAT DO THEY DO, THEY ARE ON TV
TOO.
HUNTER BIDEN LIED ON A FEDERAL
GUN FORUM.
THAT'S A FELONY.
HOW WAS HE PUNISHED?
A MILD PROBING ON CBS THAT HE
SHRUGGED OFF AS IF IT WERE
NOTHING.
WATCH.
>> WHY DID YOU HAVE A GUN?
>> AGAIN, IT WAS IT.
IN MY LIFE THAT WAS DIFFICULT.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> ACCORDING TO THE REPORTING A
ONE POINT THE SECRET SERVICE
WENT LOOKING FOR THE RECORD OF
SALE.
DO KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THAT?
>> NOTHING.
>> THEY DO KNOW ABOUT THE SECRE
SERVICE BEING INVOLVED?
>> NOT AT ALL.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS TRUE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY THE SECRET
SERVICE WERE INVOLVED.
REALLY?
YOU HAD NO IDEA?
THEY WERE WITH YOU.
THEY HELPED YOU.
YOU COMMITTED A GUN FELONY.
IT'S ALL OUT THERE.
BUT HUNTER BIDEN IS THE
PRESIDENT'S SON AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY HE'S A FAITHFUL
PARTY LOYALIST.
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS HE DOES HE
DOESN'T HAVE A THING TO WORRY
ABOUT.
HE CAN FLAUNT HIS CRIMES.
RADAR ONLINE.com GOT PICTURES
OF HIM CASUALLY WAVING HIS
ILLEGAL FIREARM AROUND WITH A
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
THE PITCHER SHOW HUNTER BIDEN'S
FINGER ON THE TRIGGER OF THE GU
AS WELL AS CRACK COCAINE AND
DRUG PARAPHERNALIA.
A WEAPON OF WAR IN THE HANDS OF
A DRUG ADDICT.
IS THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
BOTHERED BY THIS?
OF COURSE NOT.
YOU KNOW WHAT BOTHERS THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT QUITE A BIT?
DEFYING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOU DO THAT AND YOUR HOUSE GETS
RATED BY A SWAT TEAM THAT TIPS
OFF CNN BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
ROGER STONE DISCOVERED THAT THE
HARD WAY.
>> EXCLUSIVE FOOTAGE YOU ARE
LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW FROM CNN A
THE FBI ARRIVES AT ROGER STONE'
RESIDENCE IN FORT LAUDERDALE,
FLORIDA, TAKING HIM INTO CUSTODY
.
THEY ARRIVED BEFORE DAWN, JUST
AFTER 6:00 A.M.
A DOZEN OFFICERS WE ARE TOLD.
>> SO, THAT'S THE ACTUAL NORM I
YOU ARE TONY PODESTA KNOW AND
WORK FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOTHING YOU DO WILL GET YOU IN
TROUBLE AND YOU KNOW IT.
IF YOU ARE ROGER STONE YOU HAVE
NOT DONE NOTHING WRONG BUT YOU
HAVE GIVEN THE FINGER TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEY SHOW
UP AT YOUR HOUSE WITH GUNS.
THAT'S THE NORM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS UPHOLDING.
SERVE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
YOU WILL BE REWARDED EVEN IF YO
ARE A FELON.
ALMOST EXACTLY THE MOMENT THE
DOJ WAS PUTTING PETER NAVARRO I
SHACKLES, THE DOJ WAS DROPPING
MORE SERIOUS CHARGES AGAINST TH
TWO LEFT-WING LAWYERS THAT TRIE
TO INCINERATE COPS AND BURN THE
TO DEATH IN THEIR PATROL CARS.
THIS PAIR HAD FACED 30 YEARS IN
JAIL ON TERRORISM CHARGES BUT
THAT WAS TOO TOUGH FOR THE BIDE
DOJ.
WHY?
THEY GOT THE REPUBLICANS.
LIZ CHENEY IS NOT GIVING YOU A
LECTURE ON THE PEOPLE TRYING TO
BURN POLICE OFFICERS TO DEATH
ARE A THREAT TO THE DEMOCRACY.
IGNORE THEM.
IT NEVER HAPPENS.
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
AND CALIFORNIA CAREER FELON
CALLED TONY WALKER EXECUTED A 19
-YEAR-OLD BERKELEY STUDENT
CALLED SETH SMITH.
HE WALKED UP FOR NO REASON HAD
NEVER SEEN HIM BEFORE AND
EXECUTED HIM.
HE FIRED A GUN INTO THE BACK OF
HIS HEAD.
WHY DID HE DO THIS?
IT WAS A RACIALLY MOTIVATED
ATTACK.
IF THAT HE SAID THAT, HERE'S TH
INTERESTING THING.
A GUY WAS EXECUTED BECAUSE THE
THE WRONG SKIN COLOR.
SOUND LIKE A HATE CRIME.
MERRICK GARLAND'S DOJ DID NOT
PUSH CHARGES.
A MONTH AGO PROSECUTORS CAUGHT
AN UNBELIEVABLE DEAL WITH WALKER
.
THEY SENTENCE HIM ON A SINGLE
CHARGE OF, BRACE YOURSELF,
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER.
HE EXECUTED A COLLEGE STUDENT.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE VOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS TREND WITH
PEOPLE DYING.
NOTHING DESTROYS LEGITIMACY OF
OUR INSTITUTION MORE THAN
POLITICIZE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU CANNOT HAVE THAT.
JUSTICE MUST BE BLIND IF THERE
IS A SINGLE INSTITUTION WE HAVE
TO PRESERVE FOR THE SAKE OF OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN.
IT IS OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM AND TH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT
SERVE IT.
THEY CANNOT BE CORRUPT.
IF THEY ARE CORRUPT, IT'S PRETT
HARD TO LIVE HERE.
LIZ CHENEY AND NANCY PELOSI AND
THE REST OF THE LUNATICS ON THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE HAVE DONE
FAR MORE DAMAGE TO THIS
DEMOCRACY THEN THE RIOTERS EVER
DID.
FAR MORE WORK AND NOW THEY ARE
TRYING TO MAKE IT WORSE.
AXE EOC IS REPORTING THAT SOME
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, QUOTE
ONE BIG CHANGES ON VOTING RIGHT
AND TO ABOLISH THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
ABOLISHING THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
?
IF YOU ARE AGAINST THAT, OF
COURSE, YOU ARE UNDERMINING
DEMOCRACY.
>> WAS IT A CONSPIRACY?
>> CERTAINLY, IF YOU LOOK AT TH
COURT FILINGS.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE IT WAS A
CONSPIRACY?
>> I DO.
AT SIX LAMELY BROAD AND WELL
ORGANIZED.
REALLY CHILLING.
>> IT IS REALLY CHILLING.
WHAT IS REALLY CHILLING IS WHEN
THEY GET TO ARREST PEOPLE NOT
BECAUSE THEY VIOLATED MEANINGFU
LAWS OR POSE A THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES, BUT BECAUSE THEI
POLITICS ARE UNACCEPTABLE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE GIVEN THE
FINGER TO PEOPLE LIKE LIZ CHENEY
.
IS LIZ CHENEY OKAY WITH THAT?
WE TEXTED LIZ CHENEY ON FRIDAY.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THIS?
THEY DIRECTED ARRESTED A 72
-YEAR-OLD MAN.
DOESN'T THAT CROSS A LINE?
WILL YOU SAY SOMETHING ABOUT IT?
SHE DID NOT RESPOND.
THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE HAS JUS
HIRED A FORMER PRODUCER OF GOOD
MORNING AMERICA CALLED JAMES
GOLDSTON.
HE WILL OVERSEE THE PRIMETIME
HEARINGS ON THURSDAY NIGHT.
THE SHOW TRIAL NOW HAS A
PRODUCTION CREW.
THEY WILL BE COVERING THAT IN
GREAT DETAIL